is there a guess that you still want to
have on the show we put a word out to
the queen
no really yeah if she wants to play beer
pong whatever
her majesty wants we will do
no luck with her majesty just yet but
the tonight show has plenty of star
power this month demi lovato and meg the
stallion are set to co-host and madonna
is among special guests madonna is a
troublemaker so how do you prepare for
someone's life run for the hills you
just come in you go oh my god throw out
any notes that you had throw out
madonna's going to be madonna
someone else that we absolutely love
seeing on the show
your daughters
hello
they are so stinking cute jimmy so where
are they gonna be on the big stage no
they started getting their heads started
getting too big they started getting
more famous than these so i go yeah i
don't like this so i took them out of
the show and i've replaced them with
actor children who are just better
behave than my actual real children yeah
and they love me and they save their
lives and leave the room like actors
should do i love having my daughters you
know on the show but it got to a point
where they were just
really they were just booing jokes that
they didn't like and i was like hey i
don't know if i like this in addition to
late nights jimmy has another project in
the works with jennifer lopez we both
have kids i know she's a great mom so i
go maybe we can work in a children's
book where she goes yeah that's a good
idea let's go that way i'm like would
you ever want to do like a thing that
could teach kids how to speak spanish or
some way to make it cute and she was
like that's perfect jlo could be a guest
co-host with you ben could be in on the
act as well and then why don't you do
like a formal wedding for them you could
officiate i'm sure that's such a great
we'll get austin butler and he could do
elvis for you and if jimmy wasn't busy
enough he's also bringing back the
classic game show password debuting
august 9th on nbc jon hamm came in a
little cocky yeah well
john hamm yeah he's a big deal he's in
the biggest movie in like the last 30
years right and mad men i mean hello get
over yourself and he's so good-looking
when he comes in i'm like oh my god is
there a mirror
i can't believe no oh it's not it's john
hill it doesn't seem like that
right kiki palmer by the way she's
crushing it she is she is crushing it
she is the secret sauce to everything
awesome i love her so much we always had
fun good chemistry on the show but with
this with password just working off each
other she's fast she's quick she's so
cool and i just love working with her
let's put your password skills to the
test real quick
news news
news yep
no it's one word
yeah
news
yeah
one word
i mean really i thought that was good
y'all showbiz
oh my god no jenny it's a harder game
than it looks okay another word um
tonight entertainment
[Music]